now if I played a year with Tom Brady
what do you think is going to happen
when I play with Tom Brady I'm gonna
have a lot of stats
with Stats come success will come
attention will come so now a god about
the name of uh darrenheitner you
probably know him local guy I know
during course you know of course so now
it's the off season of that year now the
NFL is investigating me
I give them all my phones when they
investigate Tom Brady they don't take
his phones when Tom Brady need 15 days
off he get it when I need to cut days
off cause I got I'm crazy if I miss the
media I'm on TV you know so that's why I
have problems with yeah that's what I
have problems with so it's like
now I go to the Patriots and I get a
chance to have success but now the NFL
is ran by owners that's corrupt so what
do you think they do they set me up in
the media darrenheiter who is not even
my lawyer who were friends with jeroza
house they let him accept the suit on my
behalf which is a girl that's claiming
sexual assault